Archer les voitures en fait un
personnage très important dans le film et elle
est belle le premier jour où j'ai pu
conduire la voiture je pense que trois jours nous avons tourné
là-bas nous avions huit voitures et je pense que nous avons
complètement cassé deux
rappelez-vous que le cascadeur tribal est pour dire
allez pour cette fois vous savez donc j'ai l'air
absolument périlleux parce que c'est
absolument
périlleux c'était juste épique c'est les seuls mots que
vous pouvez décrire avec des motos qui se
retournent et des voitures qui volent je
veux dire que c'était fou j'ai hâte que
tout le monde le fasse  voir cette section,
vous savez que c'est
une aventure à indice d'octane élevé alimentée par l'adrénaline, c'est une
montagne russe absolue
vous